But it will be a while
before we can test this in our code.
We still are going to implement
a whole layer on top of it
along with a bunch of UI changes.
Fortunately, we can implement
JUnit test here to help.
And now for some magic.
We'll add a directory
to the source directory
of our Android studio project
called Android test, and then
another one underneath it
called Java.
This is the way we tell Android studio
there's a test target in cradle
for our app.
Now we create a test package
that matches our main package
with an extra test directory on the end.
Create a new class called "fullTestSuite"
in the test package.
Add this code.
This is some boiler plate code
that will allow us to add tests
and additional classes.
Next, we'll create a TestDB class
that extends Android test case,
and add a test that creates our DB.
The way this works is that the test-runner
will execute every function in our class
that begins with "test" in the order that
they are declared in the class.
Each test should have a failure path
that uses an assert.
We start by deleting the database
before testing it,
so, we have a clean test.
Now, to run the test,
we go to the app start drop down
and select Edit Configurations.
We select Plus
to add a new configuration,
and select Android Tests
against Module App.
Now we name the test.
Now note that it tends to target
the emulator by default.
I want to use an actual device,
I'm going to select
Show Chooser Dialogue.
Now we can just run the test
against our device.
And it passes.
So, let's create a database insert
and read test.
At the beginning of it, we'll insert
a single record into each table.
We'll begin with some dummy data
for our location.
We'll use the DBHelper
to get a writable database.
This is exactly how we will use
the database
when we code it up in our project.
We'll then create a ContentValues object,
which is a handy helper object
that Android uses
to store values and keys.
We'll store our dummy data
into the columns
from our LocationEntry contract.
Note that in order to make it work
with this abbreviated syntax,
I did have to add
some extra imports up here.
We then insert the data
into our database,
and verify that we got a row back.
Now I find that it's helpful
to put log messages into my test cases.
Now we'll use the database
read operations
to pull our dummy data
back out of the data base.
We're making use
of a custom projection here,
which, in theory, would make it easy
to use our database cursor
to query for the values we want.
We use a custom projection here.
Although, it's not required.
If the custom projection wasn't there,
we would simply return all columns.
A database cursor
is a control structure
that enables traversal
over the records in a database.
In Android, this is represented by
a cursor object.
The cursor object allows one
to traverse between records in a query
and get the contents
of any individual column from a query.
Now, we use cursor.moveToFirst
to populate our cursor
with our row of data.
We can then pull out our data by index.
Finally, assert if it doesn't match
our dummy data.
And now, we get to run our tests again.
And they passed.